we put drills and calibration tools so
my foot maneuvers and I'm gonna drill up
and I change my stance I mean upon me at
the right angle so I'm not in Pisa okay
and my timing has to be that my hand my
hand is hitting him okay my hands not
jammed and then I stepped by pulling
with this side step into this pocket
here from the base once the face loses
connection
that's my good arm still keep him in
front of you not behind you you keep
pulling this armbar
all right this is what keeps him in
front of you don't watch him over here
I keep him front of me I could jab
myself to here you see my arm is champs
it's a matter of timing degree of
rotation rate of rotation and you know
you're not jammed you see you're not Jim
I have a different size of our
ok2say Mike are you beyond arranged one
here I make this work
whoa you see arms in the same exact my
isn't it find the same thing wrong
you see same exact position same exact
thing you see I know that it looks like
this when I do the initial Bushido tank
on I want you to point this in space you
see it mark up a point
this one it doesn't move okay so you go
you anchor your point and I go like this
no I leave it there you see and I go
round it and then once I'm disengaging
what I'm going to do is not pull it I
can't
I'm going to move it this way you see
how to do that okay so it's going this
way it's not going this way okay and
we're gonna trade places going around
you see that now you guys come on
yes I turned it into space before and
then I'm moving his arm this way you see
where I can move it doesn't want to go
that way so one he goes this way you see
okay and now we have his balance right
and I'm gonna just sit down into this
empty space change the geometry change
the geometry okay this is just a check
that's not always kinda more with this
I'm gonna go I'm gonna go around the
grip I've gone around the grip he's
gonna get that you know I'm not gonna
crank this like that
you get that and I'm going to go around
the grip there it is right there
he gets up and I stay with this one this
way it's got to be that way because you
don't have a perfect see you cute she's
not gonna roll him over I get kind of
get here on his knuckles and then I
finished it at that he kind of gets up
into the wall so if anything he's trying
to keeping it close to you okay and then
you turn in your body here okay
around it one more time yeah I have it
there but watch what happens
I have the full lock and without doing
that I go around the arm blending with
it going around it I have that come see
it
when I when I now when she don't tank on
the second time I'm right in position
stood his hand goes there
hugs up to here you know it's fitting
body there it is one this is a good
skill this is the same skill that allows
you to deviate without moving you're
having to move your feet and you can get
angles a deviation with just your body
okay but - it's not like Tito what
you're doing and then three you know you
won't have the muscle to do what you
think you're doing you know you don't
turn somebody's ripped over hey how much
you weigh well let's find out get inside
of that man
you get turned by risk for some time
yeah sure go let's go I won't even
anchor my elbow no you're just not gonna
do it what am I gonna do am I gonna sit
here like this though take his eye out
okay so it's not like you you're
misunderstanding that Nicky horn okay so
it's in the beginning where I see I know
I'm not pulling on that I'm gonna round
it I'm on the other side now you see
that originally I was in the front on
the knuckles you see that
so the reconciliation is I'm on the
inside now is this I'm not he's not
pushing on anything now right okay and
then we go and I'm gonna do the same
thing I'm gonna go around it I'm gonna
go around it not stay here and turn it
okay I just holding this here it's not
very hard is it okay and it's so he gets
up all the way right and I go to here
that was all I need that's it that's all
I want and then I'm going to move to
this side I want to move my body I'm not
going to go like this I'm gonna move my
body do you see and then you have it and
I'd leave it right there I tie it and
then we come back down that's the tick
okay I'm not I'm not turning you my
body's going around your fist okay okay